seit mehr als 100 jahren wird hier
metall geschmolzen
die von der gießerei im
baden-württembergischen singen ist einer
der größten zulieferer für gussteile
hinter autoindustrie fertigt für daimler
und volkswagen
die gießerei benötigt so viel strom wie
eine kleinstadt und dieser strom muss
grün werden sagt der chef
ja unsere zielgruppe industriepartnern
von uns dass wir natürlich auch so
schnell wie möglich klimaneutral werden
klimaneutral bedeutet die gießerei
braucht erneuerbare energie in großen
mengen und da schon bald um den standort
mit seinen rund 800 arbeitsplätzen zu
sichern
doch grüner strom ist knapp im grünen
regierten baden-württemberg
die bilanz der grünen regierung in baden
württemberg ist diesbezüglich wir haben
bis jetzt in der ganzen gegend hier nur
ein paar zusätzliche windräder bekommen
dazu der eurobahn energien lässt zu
wünschen übrig da wäre viel wärmeenergie
dabei hatte der erste grüne
ministerpräsident deutschlands winfried
kretschmann viel versprochen
im mai 2011 bei seiner antrittsrede im
landtag präsident meine damen und herren
unser ziel ist es deshalb die
erneuerbaren energien bis zum jahr 2020
zu einer zentralen säule der
stromerzeugung zu machen
deshalb werden wir die blockaden bei der
windkraft beseitigen
kretschmann und seine landesregierung
setzten sich ein klares ziel
festgeschrieben im koalitionsvertrag
2011 mit der spd
zitat wir wollen bis 2020 mindestens
zehn prozent unseres stroms aus
heimischer windkraft decken
das ziel wird klar verfehlt statt zehn
prozent stammen 2009 10 nur 4,4 prozent
des verbrauchten stroms aus windkraft
dabei ist der wille für mehr erneuerbare
energie vor ort häufig da wie im kleinen
wiesental im schwarzwald vor rund zehn
jahren nahmen hier bürger die
energiewende selbst in die hand
heute werden rund 60 haushalte über
nahwärmenetze versorgt die energie dafür
liefern holzhackschnitzel aus der
umgebung weiß ich einfach überwältigt
wie hoch die bereitschaft war mit dem
gebäude als navigation ihren wir haben
mittlerweile den anschlussgrad von über
90 prozent
die leute machen mit die leute ziehen
voll mit viele bürger vor ort wollen
mehr windräder sollen auf einem nahe
gelegenen berg rücken aufgestellt werden
der gemeinderat hat bereits vor sieben
jahren zugestimmt
doch ein baubeginn ist immer noch nicht
absehbar
die bürger vermissen den rückenwind
durch die landesregierung
ich denke hätten ja von anfang an mehr
unterstützung gekriegt von der
landespolitiker bei diesem projekt bei
der umsetzung werden wir sicher schon
einen schritt weiter
ich schätze den herrn kretschmann
grundsätzlich sehr aber wenn er sich mit
dem selben engagement für die
windenergie einsetzen würde wer sich für
den dieselmotor einsetzt dann werden wir
in baden württemberg und auch hier im
kleinen wiesental weiter mit der
entwicklung
der zubau der windkraft stockt in baden
württemberg unter dem grünen
ministerpräsidenten kretschmann wurden
seit 2011 im schnitt gerade einmal 103
10 megawatt windkraft pro jahr zu gebaut
um die klimaschutzziele von paris bis
2030 zu erreichen müsste viel mehr
zugebaut werden
690 megawatt pro jahr das ist das
sechsfache schöner im schwarzwald vor 27
jahren gründeten bürger hier die
elektrizitätswerke schönau und zeigen
was möglich ist
sie produzieren heute mehr grünen strom
als der ort selbst verbraucht als vor
zehn jahren der grüne winfried
kretschmann ministerpräsident wurde war
die hoffnung groß
ja das hat natürlich also für die
energiewende bewegten in baden
württemberg natürlich eine art von
ausbruch stimmung gegeben der erste
grüne ministerpräsident in baden
württemberg nach jahrzehntelanger
cdu-regierungen da haben wir schon alle
erwartet das ist jetzt richtig vorangeht
doch die erwartungen wurden enttäuscht
sebastian sladek führt uns in ein
industriegebiet in lahr hier in der
rheinebene liefert die sonne über das
jahr gesehen besonders viel energie
eigentlich ideal für die erzeugung von
solarstrom
es ist völlig unverständlich warum diese
dächer nicht voll mit solarzellen sind
da die gehören dazwischen drauf wie sitz
der verbraucher ja unterm dach ja also
das meer das meer wirklich verbrauchs
nahe erzeugung at its best
[Musik]
auf diesen gewerbehallen könnten
solarzellen jedes jahr strom für
tausende haushalte produzieren
seit zehn jahren hing baden württemberg
hinterher hat pro einwohner rund 20
weniger solarzellen installiert als im
bundesschnitt
und das trotz grünen-regierungschef und
viel sonne im süden
wir bilden uns wahnsinnig viel einen auf
unsere klugen köpfen auf die viele
industrie die wir haben
stand heute lassen wir uns den ganzen
regenerativen strom aber in
norddeutschland produzieren das geht so
nicht ja völlig klar dass wir den strom
den wir hier brauchen auch hier erzeugen
sollten in baden württemberg in baden
württemberg
und weil seit 2011 dem regierungsantritt
von kretschmann so wenig
solarstromanlagen zu gebaut wurden
müsste jetzt umso mehr passieren
für die klimaschutzziele 2030 braucht es
1170 megawatt pro jahr drei mal so viel
wie bisher
[Musik]
der grüne ministerpräsident winfried
kretschmann ist im wahlkampf sein
klimaziel klimaneutral im märz bilder
wiedergewählt werden
wir wollen wissen warum er seine eigenen
ziele verfehlt hat kretschmann verweist
an seinen umweltminister franz
untersteller der teilt mit die
landesregierung habe die
selbstgesteckten ziele erreicht und am
schleppenden ausbau sei die
bundesregierung schuld
zitat natürlich wünschen wir uns
insgesamt ein schnelleres ausbautempo
bei den erneuerbaren in deutschland da
muss mehr getan werden von der
bundesregierung
dabei zeigen nachbarländer dass es
besser geht
trotz bundesregierung 2009 10 hatte rein
rheinpfalz 51,7 prozent grünen strom
anteil hessen 51 prozent unter schwarze
bayern 1 50,2 ausgerechnet das grüne
baden württemberg belegt mit 31,5
prozent einen der letzten plätze
bundesweit
wenn der ausbau erneuerbarer energien
nicht so erfolgt wie erfolgen muss dann
werden natürlich konventionelle
kraftwerke und gaskraftwerke
kohlekraftwerke auch in zwanzig dreißig
noch stark betrieben werden und die
klimaziele in baden württemberg nicht
erreicht werden das heißt trotz grüner
landesregierung werden dann im jahr 2030
pariser klimaschutz ziele verfehlt
werden
das kann passieren ja der erste grüne
ministerpräsident deutschlands hatte
zehn jahre zeit und er hat nicht
geliefert
[Musik]